there is like no one out there right now
that is on Jenna Ortega's level this
girl should be legendary for the extreme
levels of prep work she put into her
work especially if we're talking about
Wednesday well it turns out that
sometimes you don't need to prepare so
much if you just really commit to a
crazy idea that comes to you in the
Moment Like apparently her audition came
the exact same day that she was filming
her bloody end of the movie scene for X
instead of changing or getting a shower
like a normal person would she decided
to show up to her audition still covered
in fake blood I wore prosthetic I had
Cuts all over my face and Stage blood
and sweat in my hair not only that but
she'd been awake for like over 24 hours
already she was
disgusting for any other audition this
probably would have been a red flag for
Wednesday though the only thing better
would be if she showed up with a cello
and a bag full of piranhas